d aging bringing people back from the
dead this is the twilight zone
I'm Greg I'm John we have a patron video
request here from youtuber who passed a
thousand followers recently Omni media
Michael B Jordan he has a very specific
request a topic that he would like us to
discuss here his full message reads
something like this for this month's
video requests Vin Diesel he released a
photo from the set of fast nine with
Paul Walker's brother hinting that
Brian's presence this is my impression
of my Bill Hader impression using his
brother as a CGI transfer body double
and do you think they should have Brian
O'Connor / Paul Walker appear in the
film
post-mortem or leave it be I say yes D
age Michelle Rodriguez while you're at
it she's looking gray oh we have seen
this with Peter she's like the baddest
ass one of them we have seen this with
Peter Cushing and rogue one and discuss
when involving Carrie Fisher and rise of
ski blogger how do you feel about doings
how do you feel you know even with the
family's consent how do we feel about it
yeah this comes off the heels of this
Vin Diesel posts about possibly alluding
to having Paul Walker's character return
here I think it would be fascinating to
see it done just to see the outrage and
the outpouring of weird support - yes
yes
it's so it's difficult for me to imagine
what layer of context this is
appropriate I think I think it's only
appropriate currently at least maybe
they'll pull it off one day and be like
[ __ ]
Brandon was great in that lead they
pulled him over from the DC like wow
he's awesome
III don't know which like going forward
but I think it's alright for you know
like like a fast seven furious seven
ones called part seven I think is
alright for that even what they've been
doing rise of Skywalker I think that's
okay because of the feather they did
shoot some footage and you know we're
we've tried doing things in the past
already where you just get some double
to show up and like Brandon Lee's The
Crow had had some doubles in there and I
think that was if I'm not mistaken I I
believe they actually did do some like
90 CGI to the face to make it look more
like him interest I've seen the movie in
a few I grew up watching the chrome like
for so many years but I didn't actually
haven't seen it that I can't recall any
specific moments but I remember Bruce
Lee's last movie that he directed and
starred in Game of Death there's another
actor who fills in for him because he
died during production
oh she's kind of weird because there's a
funeral scene for the character and they
used Versys actual like footage from his
real funeral oh wow strange Wow and then
the other actor who is who's clearly not
Bruce Lee so cases like that you know
like well they did all this work is not
complete unless we'd you know we can't
complete this without them and this
person was on board to complete this
from the get-go yeah yeah so I think
that's fine I think it's freaking weirdo
if we got a brand new like this were
fast like fast and furious no my god I
don't know why Vin Diesel's under this
impression that this is a franchise that
is deep one of the thing is they Paul
Walker's brothers have extrapolated a
bit on this about the possible
of bringing Brian O'Connor back and they
the word that kept using was tasteful
and I kept thinking like what is
tasteful in a fast and the furious
context like are they only going to have
him on another kind of like he's with
his family on the beach sort of shot or
is it going to be I don't know if they
do open the door I could just see it
snowballing into he's a complete
character by the next movie
yeah and using that sort of thing well
he loved the franchise he would have
wanted this and I don't know like maybe
he would have and at a certain point I
feel like it's gonna create this weird
conversation where you've got the
family's opinion and then all of us who
don't know this person's opinion and
we'll never get the actual person's
opinions so I think for me personally at
the idea of bringing him back yeah
without some kind of completion element
is a bit ghoulish like I feel like I cuz
then it's forcing me to acknowledge it
in a whole other way yeah I think like
the more we get removed from people's
lifespans like the thing is I spent most
of rogue one thinking did Peter is this
Peter crochet still alive and then you
know partway through I was like no I'm
pretty sure I heard when he died and
then yeah and that was an effect that I
thought for most of that movie was
convincing enough that I was wondering
that and so that didn't upset me quite
to the degree that like if they said
tomorrow oh he's got a plot line in this
new Fast and the Furious movie that
would be kind of ghoulish and strange to
me and so I feel like maybe something
about the time has something to do with
this - yeah yeah I just I can't think no
wonder they had a situation where an
actor passed away that they got a
replacement actor and he was just as if
not better I can't think of a time when
actually I just finished Spartacus
season 1 and there's a the lead actor
who plays Spartacus is wonderful he's
amazing
and I found out I was prepped for this
early on that that actor that was
diagnosed with cancer and he died right
when they were about to gear up for
season 2 and he get him he said you guys
should find
one else because you know suffering me
cancer I'm probably gonna die
so they got a different actor I've only
seen one episode of season 2 which is
apparently like the best season of the
show but generally speaking most people
still prefer the actor from season
wanted and it's it's a different like
for something like that like the show's
called Spartacus you need Spartacus is
this story so it makes sense that you
got to get a replacement actor amen
everyone Spartacus pretty much so and
yeah I mean that I don't make us a whole
review about that actor who plays
Spartacus but you know it's like it's
difficult to not compare yeah because
that's and it's a difficult job for that
actor to just go like I gotta go in here
and do my own thing but I also have to
kind of make this in the likeness of
what that last actor did yeah and then
you just lend yourself upon like a first
few viewings to comparison yeah and oh
yeah obviously cuz because you're there
is like a weird gap in the continuity
where the continuity changes for an
outside force no one has control over so
you can't really fault the piece for it
but it's going to be noticeable and if
he has to try to you know duplicate that
performance it's just gonna be false
yeah and the same thing if you've got it
actor to impersonate the deceased actor
yeah it would probably be worse and
weird and no I'm not for this they
haven't they haven't even mastered
de-aging technology
it still looks best straight away like
it's the new toy and that still looks
distracting and that looks weird and I
wouldn't want to see III wouldn't be
able to see I don't know how I could
possibly get invested in it I don't how
I could possibly look past it I would
just be so distracted by what is
essentially an impersonation at this
point yeah well yeah because I've seen
inevitably what happens is you'll get an
actor to do a very similar performance
and interpret it based on them and then
yeah you'll just lay on a bunch of
algorithmically chosen sounds and you
know facial tics based on their
performances and like although I wonder
if a toy with this question a little bit
I wonder how it would be for a biopic
you know what I mean like if you were
able to do that with yeah that's why
this is bad
yeah if you were to change like Terran
edgerton's face for rocket man and make
him look like Elton John per se yeah
like how would that translate because my
issue with you know let's say sid haig
is the first one that comes to mind
because he passed away recently
rest in peace by the way let's say like
Rob's on when I do another you know
Firefly family movie yeah
if you got an actor to show up to you
know do the sid haig role yeah - like
impersonating Captain Spaulding
yeah impersonate Captain Spaulding it's
strictly just an impersonation of that
but yeah you know well that's what if
you're doing a biopic you can still you
know it's different it's it's like it's
just for existed for resurrected
characters cuz I'm find a really bizarre
if they were like let's bring said Hagin
for this role but he's dead for this
brand-new movie you know I mean the
mythology would maybe allow for that but
I mean I do think it's they would never
have had the budget for this but I did
appreciate that in the production of
that movie they went to the effort to
get as much as they could with him and
then incorporate that into the story and
then didn't give it his role to a new
character instead and what three from
hell
Oh as a new character name haven't seen
yet yeah yeah there's a new basically
the Richard break character becomes a
lot of what Spaulding would have been
doing just if there's just a new piece
of context added alright so yeah because
you know Spaulding was supposed to be in
much more of the movie and then like a
couple weeks out from production they
said they got a call and his health just
wouldn't allow it and they had to even I
guess it was trouble getting the shots
anyway because like insurance wouldn't
even ever clear him to shoot so so yeah
and then you know you think about
Hollywood and if this was a you know
much more expensive movie then you'd
have maybe and so yeah I don't I that's
the thing is this is one of those where
I feel like you're gonna right now I
feel like we should be very cautious
because this is gonna creep its way into
actors contracts and like anybody who's
gonna be here on cameras contracts now
and I feel like that is where the answer
really ought to go
as if you are I mean it's harder with
like yeah biopic rights I think is an
interesting application and that is
perhaps the most like solid argument I
think for the technology because I think
it does become sort of inherently weird
if we're just going to start
resurrecting people's likenesses and
using them however we want because
wherever you draw that line is arbitrary
but um well it's like if you look at
what they did with Captain America an
end game when he's old
yeah they had Chris Evans and make up
and then they had a I think an older
then they had an older actor and they
kind of just sliced yeah together and it
ended digital touch-ups I think
reception was a makeup yeah yeah he was
in some sort of makeup to make him look
kind of like this old guy and then the
old guy was there too it had the realism
and then he kind of married yeah yeah
and liked it and so maybe you could do
something like that with a biopic if you
put like an actor and makeup to make him
look more like him than you digital I
mean I still and that's I can't imagine
it because I'm still like but today's
technology wouldn't look good you know
yeah and that's the thing too is I feel
like the technology needs to get that
like it's almost there but it's a part
of movie magic that needs to be there
otherwise the magic isn't working yeah I
haven't seen Gemini man only the
trailers but even in that I'm like that
is some of the best that's ever looked
yeah but but I'm very still there's also
a certain amount of your brain is just
gonna fill that gap it's gonna go I know
he's alive now and that's not him yeah
and like this is the only like literally
I've just in the d aging talk the only
thing that's brought up consistently
that is that's pulled it off is and you
brought up on Collider movie talk is Sam
Jackson's the aging and hmm cat Sam
Marvel and like how you said it's
because he doesn't look his age it's
pretty it's easier to do that on him
yeah but that's one movie where he can
be like that was flawless she was in it
the whole time and he looked great so to
slap a whole new face on the deep fake
the [ __ ] 51 and the Irishman is gonna be
a big indicator too because the thing is
like every
he's hyping up that budget and stuff and
and it's funny cuz we see this
technology use the most I think in big
superhero type stuff as Marvel uses it
yeah and I'm interested to see what's
gonna happen to the technology once we
see it across a three and a half hour
drama where it's very much gonna be used
as this kind of narrative tool yeah as a
way of enhancing yeah I mean it's
essentially not the same as the biopic
but yeah you're having the same guy
mirror himself at a different point in
life so I would imagine there's a
similar kind of visual marriage because
they're getting there there's a there's
a YouTube channel forgetting the name of
it they he does these deep fakes and
it's the best I've ever seen it done and
what he does is like he I saw like the
Bill Hader once he does like when Bill
Hader breaks into an impersonation he
changes the face
and it's like already transitions are
flawless when he's breaking in to the
faith like when he does like Tom Cruise
or Arnold or Pacino it looks like looks
like him the fact that you know bill hit
her nails those impersonations down it's
believable you know you still aware of
how fake it just know where he's not
real so I should because it's just
switching in and out of his face but the
fact that it's an Alamo do do does you
basic VFX on YouTube and is able to pull
this off I can only imagine where
Hollywood can get with this I do think
though that if you're if the only way I
could possibly possibly deal with this
as if it's a for a movie that's already
like has a lot of its shot with the
actor already and they just need to
complete it if they want to do a little
can't like yeah like be talking about if
it's like Paul Walker on the beach
that's one thing but if it's like a
brand new film yeah it's like you don't
need dead actor or actress just get a
new actor yeah and I yeah I don't know I
mean again this is one of those like
Pandora's box pieces of movie magic
where I'm like there are a lot of
interesting applications I think that it
is a very broad technology and I think
we should be very careful and
considerate as to how we get used to
applying it and yeah I think ultimately
that will be the thing is personally I
would like to see us kind of accept
whose
identities we don't own on film and then
yeah allow people in the future to
decide okay yeah you can own my likeness
or or if somebody is having a biopic
made about them then they can sign that
right over under certain circumstances
like then I would feel okay because it's
under the control of whoever's likeness
it is and I think that's what's the most
important well Jimmy Hoffa we'll see
what happens guys we'll see what happens
yeah the future looks younger but
somehow weird and hexie all right guys
well what do you think of this subject I
want you to leave a comment down below
do you think this is appropriate should
we just wait to see what they're doing
they just surprised us or if it's a good
movie who cares yeah who cares right
Paul Walker punch the [ __ ] out of all
those people yeah start yeah it's just
him beating up guys who look like the
rock next fast and furious is called
Brian's thing is like this is kind of a
ghoulish joke but like III I'm afraid
that if we don't take care with this
we're so close to that ya know it could
be abused yeah all right guys well you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification bell and Michael B
thank you so much for requesting this my
dude yeah sounds like things have been
going great for you and he doesn't have
an AMC near him but he has regal so he's
been he's got the regal past like the
AMC a-list and I just wanted to say man
I hope you're abusing those points dude
what I do is I just buy tickets three
times a week and I never show up so then
by the time I go to the theater I have
like 80 dollars in points and then I buy
a bunch of food I don't even eat half of
it but then I laugh at the employees for
serving me
oh you six orders of mozzarella sticks
can equal a thing is at least one of
those orders you're literal
just throwing over your shoulder and
laughing on your way to the theater like
we only get to eat a couple of them so
abuse it man yeah by the way you asked
me for a tip on how your girlfriend and
you you know like you don't really have
the same kind of level of interest and
movies but I would say that that is
dumper and get any girl no sellout and
stop liking me pick one I would say just
make a trade-off with her what I would
do is go OK watch my movie and then
we'll watch yours you choose I choose
you choose mine shoes that simple he
doesn't like girl we don't like like her
get a new girl get some of this
technology
slap her face on that that's where this
is yeah you'll never have to let go ever